>> Bret: MARK MEREDITH ON
CAPITOL HILL, MARK, THANKS.
AND TONIGHT’S DEMOCRACY 2020
REPORT, JOE BIDEN SAYS HE IS
CONCERNED PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL
TRY TO STEAL THE NOVEMBER
ELECTION WERE REFUSED TO LEAVE
THE WHITE HOUSE IF HE LOSES.
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN SAID THE
PRESUMPTIVE NOMINEE IS
TRAFFICKING AND CONSPIRACY
THEORIES.
PETER DOOCY HAS DETAILS WHERE A
RARE PUBLIC APPEARANCE BY BIDEN
TODAY.
>> JOE BIDEN TO THE CITY OF
BROTHERLY LOVE WITH A ROUNDTABLE
DISCUSSION IN THE BUILDING WHERE
DICK CLARK USED TO BROADCAST
AMERICAN BANDSTAND.
>> I COULD NEVER DANCE.
>> CONGRESSMAN, YOU ARE TOO
YOUNG TO KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
AMERICAN BANDSTAND’S.
>> ON A LATE NIGHT COMEDY SHOW,
BUT BIDEN WAS FAR MORE SERIOUS.
>> IT IS MY GREATEST CONCERN MY
SINGLE GREATEST CONCERN OF THIS
TRAGEDY WILL TRY TO STEAL THE
ELECTION.
>> TRUMP USE THAT SAME LANGUAGE
TALKING VOTER FRAUD IN 2016.
>> TRUMPS CRITICS CONSIST OF
THOSE CLAIMS WERE UNFOUNDED IN
FOUR YEARS LATER BIDEN WITH MAIL
BALLOTS.
>> THIS IS A GUY THAT SAID ALL
MAIL IN ISLETS ARE FRAUDULENT.
SO FAR TO SUGGEST IF TRUMP LOSES
HE MAY NOT LEAVE THE WHITE HOUSE
WILLINGLY.
>> YOU HAVE SO MANY
RANK-AND-FILE MILITARY PERSONNEL
SAYING WE ARE NOT A MILITARY
STATE.
THIS IS NOT WHO WE ARE.
I PROMISE YOU AND I’M ACTUALLY
CONVINCED THEY WILL SCORE HIM
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE.
AND GREAT DISPATCH.
>> BIDEN MADE A DIFFERENT CLAIM
THAT THE PRESIDENT MAY MOVE THE
ELECTION WHICH QUICKLY HIT A
DEAD END IN THE ROSE GARDEN.
>> WHY WOULD I DO THAT?
NOVEMBER 3RD COMMIT IS A GOOD
NUMBER.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE ELECTION.
THAT WAS JUST MADE UP
PROPAGANDA.
>> SO THE ELECTION IS ON AN
BIDEN DOING HIS PART TO PREVENT
DEMOCRATIC DEFECTIONS.
>> THE IDEA THAT SOMEHOW I’VE
BEEN TOLD ALL ALONG NUMB PEOPLE
DON’T THINK I’M IN THE RIGHT
SPOT, RIGHT PLACE, THERE IS NO
POLLING EVIDENCE TO SUSTAIN THAT
NOR IS THERE VOTING EVIDENCE TO
SUSTAIN THAT.
>> THE RUNNING MATE MAY BE
NARROWING BECAUSE THE COMMITTEE
REACHED OUT TO SOME WOMEN LAST
MONTH BUT NOW ONE WOMAN WHO
PUBLICLY PUSHED HERSELF FOR THE
JOB SAID SHE HASN’T GOTTEN ANY